foreign
for CBS deals this morning we have products that
just might help you relax unwind and perhaps feel
just a bit pampered and all at exclusive low
prices to start shopping now scan the QR code
on your screen or visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle
experts Christian joins us with more good morning
so nice to see you Rochelle and so happy to be
here with Israel this morning listen we've got
some great products I want you to start with
solowave.com run and try this because this
sold out last time so pick up that wand right
there okay so the solo wave wand is red light
technology and you know you go to the spots you
get that red light technology so what does red
light technology do put it onto your skin right
now it will activate with the touch of your skin
really does is actually yeah promotes collagen it
gets rid of acne it also wrinkles put them on your
crow's feet I've actually got redness right
over here it works it works it works awesome
um and Rachel Zoe who's a style expert actually
said that this is the best beauty Budget Buy for
2021 put it on her Zoe report we're looking at
100 less than 100 and 33 percent off wow that
is a savings what about this I love luxurious
candle four-wick candle and we're talking about
Aroma 360. I lit this up in my house yesterday
fantastic yes that's why they call it Aroma 360.
essential oils uh we're talking about Bergamot
we're talking about Amber you light it up it's
four Wicks and you know people come in and look
at your house you got one two three four wigs
they look super Luxe so this is less than 100
and we're talking about a savings of 61 I love
it I've always asked the question why do we need
different glasses you need it because to have that
wine connoisseur experience and believe it or
not we're looking at the hotel collection and
this is all about five star luxurious collection
it's about five star luxury in your house you've
got white wine glasses red wine glasses and
champagne glasses that's red wine white wine
Vin salmon you're better than me you're better
than me I got a dry January going on let me give
you the deal right now we're talking about
discount of 26 off and we're talking about
under 40 44 about 44.50 right there okay what
we got here calm and cozy yes it's common cozy
and we all need to be kamikozy on these cold
days kamikozy and it's a massage heating wrap
feel how Luxe it is so basically you could
attach this strap onto your chair this thing
is portable you kind of put yourself into it it's
like a blanket but it also massages yourself it's
got a setting yeah it's perfect we're talking
about a discount of 40 off and it's less than
fifty four dollars so look at that you attach
yourself to the chair it's like you're working
from home but you're getting a massage tell
me you don't love it and this is great for
the athlete in your life as well it comes in
different colors take a look at this 40 off
go to cbsdeals.com you will love it quick question
and that's for the bottom half is there a part yes
the top half no it comes up all the way up here
okay but you know you want to be all the way up
so here we have really entrenched ourselves in
the bathroom okay I love this product because
it's called beloved bath lavender scent it came
from two moms who have autistic sons and they
wanted to create employment for kids with autism
so everything here is made with somebody who
has autism when it comes to the beautiful heart
soap we've got the lavender body butter and this
beautiful candle and so you're looking at some of
the video of some of the people that are employed
through this beautiful beloved bath now Pam and
Pat created this and so you're putting your money
where it counts we're talking about a 32 percent
discount and we're talking an exclusive deal for
38.50 go to cbsdeals.com I mean serious this is
gorgeous stuff so good so kind of thank you I
love you good to see you of course we partner
with all of these companies to get these deals
to buy anything you saw today scan that QR code
on your screen or head over to CBS deals dot com